- All right, Commodore.
Tell me where, where did you grow up?
Where were you from originally?
- I'm originally from Wichita, Kansas.
I came out to California
when I was two years old.
- And tell me about your family,
you had both your parents.
- My parents, my mom,
she's from Wichita, Kansas.
She um, my dad met her by
coming through Oklahoma.
He would go through Kansas city.
They met, he sent us out here
on a train because back then
they couldn't really afford it.
So he sent us down on the
train and he met us down here.
We grew up, I grew up on a
hundred and ninth and Avalon.
And after finishing elementary school
I resided at Roosevelt in Compton.
And that's where I started
doing my growing up at.
I grew up up there and that's
I got to Whaley guys started
wearing suspenders and hats.
They had this gang.
The thing was to beat up on white people.
Every Friday, you know,
have fights with the whites.
It wasn't that many of
them going to school
but if I wanted to be a blood
a guy named China Dog created this gang
and he was supposed to be my big homie.
And um, my initiation was to
go whoop on somebody, but it
didn't go that way I got
whooped on, but they let me in.
As I got older
I thought gangs was just a
competitor type game that who
who neighborhood can have the most money?
Who's the hardest
not in like dominating,
just killing people.
You know, as I got older, I um...
went to high school and that's
where all my bad started beginning
I started coming up out of the eggshell
and I did some things
that I'm not even proud
of right now to this day.
I've been baptized three times.
I got the certificates making it.
I'm not going to never make it
to heaven man be, you know,
to take a person's life.
That's priceless.
You know, my daughter life got tooken.
Our brother was carrying her
and she was 11 months old.
They brought her down here on a surprise.
When I was supposed to come home
from the service I was in the Navy.
That's the branch I was in.
You know, I wanted to see her so bad
but he went from party.
Every party.
When I got to Compton from San Diego,
graduating in San Diego
every party that I went
to, they said he just left.
He got your daughter.
He just left.
I had a thousand dollars for him.
I just took it out the credit union.
And that was in 79.
That was a lot of money.
And we went from party and
then we just passed the street.
Cause my sister said, we said
we going to go to the Carolina West.
It was eight of us in the 73 gremlin
all gang members, ladies, and
we had a shotgun in tge car.
We got the dog in the car.
We went to this, we was
getting ready to go home
to take my sister, to get her shoes.
But as we was going home
we was coming down long beach Boulevard.
This was December 22nd, 1979.
This was around 11 o'clock, 11:15.
I still had on my uniform and
we looked down the street.
It was a gang
of police on the street,
right by looters park.
We've seen a guy laying
in the street by a car.
We thought he was working on it.
So we turned down the street
where the police was at.
We went all the way up to this person.
The person looked us in his face.
He looked us in the face
and I was like man, you all right, man.
Why are you blocking the road?
When we backed up
the police told us to get
up out of there, serious.
As we were leaving, we was going on.
We said I wonder what's wrong with him?
Why he just laying there in the street?
This is what my little sister telling him
me and my oldest sister
sitting by the door.
So we get home and pull up
in the driveway for her
to get her shoes on.
When my mother come through
the door, I said, mama
we couldn't find Duke at
the party was Claudia.
That was my baby's name.
My mother said, y'all need
to go to the hospital.
They just called and said, dude got shot.
But to make the story short
on our way to the hospital
it's a club called the
brothers, had a sign.
It said, man...
(exhales)
It's this club.
And as we was going by this club
I was driving. This car, it just pulled
up in front of us out of nowhere, man,
and we just banged it.
I mean, shit.
We was flying to the hospital.
I jumped out the car to go
see if this guy was all right
because I'm carrying my own burden
And when I was running
to the car.
Cause we knocked him out.
We knocked him.
Well, he just like (crash sound).
This happened that quick.
And I couldn't do nothing.
I didn't even blink eyes.
And I was looking at my sister and him.
They was under the dashboard
But they were fine.
So I ran to his car to
see if he was alrl right.
I said, Mr.
But I guess he was thought I
was coming in aggressively.
He pulled a gun on me.
Man and grabbed me man.
And I was like, Aw man.
That's where I'm at, man.
I'm just a kid.
18 years old.
No, I'm 17 because my mother had signed
for me going and now you
say, man, what's wrong?
I said, man, I'm just
going to the hospital.
My brother just got shot.
So we was in a hurry.
He said, well man, I'm all right
y'all go on and go.
The car rode, but every time
you hit a bump at the fender rub
it was a 73 gremlin.
So when we get
up to the hospital, they,
no, the police came.
And as we talk to the police
which his name was black
Reggie, he was on Suge Knight's
Also, on Suge Knight's payroll
Reggie came and said, I say, Reggie.
Me and my sister, man, we gotta go
to the hospital, I don't know who was
right and who was wrong,
but my brother just got shot.
And he said man, a whole lot
people getting shot tonight.
He said, a guy just got
shot down the street.
And I'm like, what you mean?
And my sister say who?
He say some little black
dude, 'bout your height man.
He say he got shot.
So he just died.
And this, when he said
that the paramedics went
by the man turned to her
he didn't say nothing about a child.
He said nothing about a child
but to make a long story short
that guy that I rode up
on, I didn't see the baby.
They removed, they moved the baby.
That was my brother I was talking to
But he couldn't talk.
It was a lady behind the gate.
The same time with these grapevines only.
She was communicating with him
for a while where he laid in the street.
He was shot eight times, with a 30-06
close range, up on the door. Um...
And he was holding the baby.
My baby was messed up, man.
I came home on emergency leave.
This is where my, my career
as me and the service man
which is my Navy Eagle right here.
And my triangle in my career
as a good guy, it just left right there.
My daughter, my brother
I can shoot a distance without a scope.
Real good.
And they seen it in the service too.
I shoot birds and stuff.
A guy came up missing by a school.
A girl said a guy pulled up in a car
pulled a gun out of the trunk.
She said, he said it on a gate, he shot
across the school and left,
jumped in the car and left.
He was driving with
some wrenches, which was
they was trying to say
a pair of vice grip.
She say, well the angle, the direction
that this guy was shooting
was just supposed to be me.
She say, I put a rifle on the
gate and shot in a dice game.
But she said, I wouldn't shoot him.
She said, I shot one time.
They say that guy grabbed the back
of his head and failed on
the other side of the school.
They said, this guy just
got in the car and he left.
Then another guy
these supposed to been the
guy that was in the car.
There was three people in the car
and all the names was in the paper.
Another guy got shot in
the face at the light.
So, um...
that's what we call, putting in work.
I have friends that was
from my neighborhood.
They wanted to deliver, but I did my own.
I paid my own.
They came up and started
investigating my case.
I, in a way they put the story together
as like Looters Park is a known gang.
(unclear).
Crips is a known gang.
It's going to be a retaliation, a dude
and his kid and a cute
little girl got shot
so they already know
how that retaliation go.
But it's just a matter of time of when.
So they started doing this investigation
and I guess they say, well
let me see this guy got any
brothers and stuff like this.
And next thing you know, I get paid.
I get an unexpected visit in San Diego.
They told me I have to go
to the legal office and talk to somebody.
So I dismissed myself from my company
which we was finna do a swimming drill.
And I left.
And when I went in there,
I got kind of nervous
and things because I
already know I'm gonna see
if I can just be cool, play this off.
Cause I know that I knew
what this is about, man.
He said, well, come Mr.
Marshall, we have a guy
about murder and whoop whoop.
And this guy is the shot
in the back of the neck
through the back, through
the neck, through the head.
And they said, Hey,
you know, it was funny.
And he said, it just, I like that.
He said, you know, it's funny.
You the only one can shoot like that.
And you was at home on emergency.
Leave the red cross.
He'd go, yo papers.
During the time this guy got shot.
I said bullshit. (unclear)
So what would make you think I could
shoot a guy like that?
I could shoot a BB gun,
you know, playing stupid
(unclear)
It really, he said, I got your ass.
I said, no, you don't.
So the way they did me, man
I thought I wasn't gonna see them no more.
They send me to a general
court martial in the service.
The service said we're
going to deal with our own.
So they send me to a general court martial
but we went and did something else.
Before I got arrested
we went back through
these guys neighborhood.
There was A, uh, AR-15.
There's a lot of guns involved.
A lot of people got hurt.
And that was just our way of celebrating.
And those are deep scars for both sides
the Crips
guys that I knew that wore blue rags
and I mean real notorious gangs.
And this is where we get our stripes at.
They say, I have a name
of a leader, instead
of calling me general.
They just call them Commodore
by my first name because
it's a leading officer.
It's in the dictionary.
I know what my name means.
So they ranked me out and we
ain't supposed to live to be 58
or you don't die about 26, 27.
If you don't get, like, I went to prison
I served 26 and a half years.
I started off at San Diego in the brig.
They convicted, but with
a BCD, not a dishonorable
a bad kind of discharge.
So they transferred me to San Diego.
I stayed in their brig, which was bad
because I never did time in my life.
And I was still young and I just didn't.
I threw my life away.
So they transferred me from
San Diego to great lakes
Illinois and great lakes,
Illinois, a brig up there.
And from there they transfer
me, after that I did
Seven, seven years,
seven and a half years.
So almost eight years
in, I don't know the name
of great lakes, Illinois,
brig, but it's, it's a big one.
They transferred me to the feds.
Did eleven in the feds.
I paroled out of Calipatria state prison.
That's how they broke my time up.
I paroled in 2008.
I haven't looked back.
Then, then I started coming down here
and started buying pussy
and smoking crack cocaine.
Cause I've my equilibrium
felt like it was fucked up.
I wasn't balanced.
Excuse my language.
But my life just wasn't balanced, man.
It's just (unclear).
I didn't think that I would be living in
that phase, just to...
Oh, I'm a gang member.
And every word that came out
of my mouth was blood, blood
but some guys said it's, it's a front.
I said it 'cause I meant it, you know.
And...
- (unclear)
- I, um...
Her old man is my big homie.
- What's that?
- Her old man is my big
homie from Looter's Park.
- Oh is that right?
Yeah. If you met him, Walt. Big Walt.
He's mine straight...
we call him gangster.
Hey, he raised me.
But um...
If I could take a lot of
things back, I ain't scared to
say this on camera.
Cause you got to prove it.
There's five lives missing.
Probably more than that.
I just never stayed to see
It's got a dream that. Doing that.
But I think...
God showed favor with me.
I believe in God.
I wish I could take
these things back, man.
The hurt that we put on people that hurt
that you have to put on
yourself when you're doing it
thinking it's going to
be cool, but it's not
really cool to watch a person die.
You know, it's not cool.
It's not cool to shoot nobody.
I did.
Every time I get a chance to
try to help somebody today
I try, I try to help them, man, because...
I fucked up.
I did and I can roll this
fam to next year, man
with some serious shit if help.
Being raised, I can raise big Suge Knight.
He's my little homie from Looters Park.
Tupac.
He got killed.
All this shit.
It was retaliation over all.
It's just like when he got killed
the night Tupac got killed.
Look what happened to Compton.
Our neighborhood gets
together, they stupid.
Twenty-five, and this, you can
I know you can look that
up. You, you y'all do your homework.
25 people within one hour
got killed at the lights
all at the lights, Crips
is dead, anybody that
represent a bad boy was just dead.
They put Compton on lockdown.
But what I see right now,
and this is my daughter, man
I'm 58 years old right now.
Got stuck down here.
I was strung out over rock cocaine.
I was buying, buying pussy, smoking it in.
Oh, women beat me, they beat me bad.
I'm going to the clinic
getting shots damn near
in the back of the neck.
You know, it can't be right.
You know, it's good.
But I lived that life, man.
That's the life that I chose, man.
I was down here since the eighties
and I watched a lot of people
go down here the same way.
It's a lot of notorious
gang members down here, man
that when they say they
don't care, they don't
but they have a lot of respect and it's
it's come a long way since
I'm kinda glad.
And I thank God they got
police on the street too.
I used to couldn't stand it.
I love it when they hit the corner, man
You saving my ass, man.
I'm telling you to go on like that now.
So say it's funny how you can go
from a bad guy, the bad boy stereotype.
However you want to see it
to this guy that just wants peace.
This I don't want no
problems with nobody, man.
I don't want no problems with nobody.
There's another.
That is another side of me.
I don't like that side.
Like I said, I've been
baptized three times.
This little guy got papers up
in a gym over at the midnight
153 pounds over at the lion guard.
Eighth floor maxed everybody out
at a hundred and no 440 on the bench.
And I only weighed one
48, won three gold medals.
This little guy took
what the Navy told him.
Did the opposite shit with it.
You know.
It wasn't by choice.
It was because I lost my daughter.
So
I've been, I've been doing all right.
I still don't know how to
express myself from being
isolated so long sometime the
way I even talk just normally
in my expression, always stay like this.
People get it misconstrued.
As you know, they think
something wrong with me.
That dude finna nut up on
you, like you say hi to him
he gonna slap the shit out of
you or something, you know?
But I'm not, you know what I mean?
(unclear)
But I always had this
look like this, you know?
Cause that's just, I got
a habit of watching people
man. I could feel people too
Just want to have a normal life.
And you know, sometime I don't
think my life will be normal
until I'm dead and gone
because it's the things.
And the thoughts that, that, that was left
behind the dust is still in there.
I have in here.
I still see some people's
family members, you know?
And it just, so I say, if
I can take back some things
I would, I seen some things in my friends.
Did I seen some things
that was did to my friends.
We weren't always the one,
the tough one to get away
during my school years.
I wish my mom was here to
tell you All my friends
is basically dead.
I was like went to his funeral.
We went to funeral, was
like, we go to parties.
And if anybody hear that,
They're going to tell
you that I'm serious.
And I know you probably
heard it more than one time.
That's how it is in the gang.
We don't ever get to go.
And he's always said, guess who died?
Guess who dead?
He got killed last night,
but you never thought
you were here.
Your brother and your daughter, me telling
my neighbors.
They was glad to see me.
Hey, they come running to
me that they ain't know.
And we all just coming from the hospital.
Cause my daughter and
my brother got killed.
And it was like, what's
wrong with you man?
You overwhelmed or something.
And we told them nah. Dude
got killed last night, which
with Claudia and they jut fell out, man,
It's just like my mom now.
I never thought they would die.
I thought they would just live forever
They were my heroes, you
know your mom and dad go.
You like your daughter and your brother
Shit.
Maybe this might've been
a good hideout for me
that this is a place down
there where you can just
nut the fuck up and they ain't going to
even pay you don't mind.
You can stand on the...
(laughs)
It's funny.
You go stand on the sidewalk and holler
and piss at the same time
and throw some at somebody
Police just gonna keep going.
(laughs)
They gonna say, he be all
right when we come back around
do it somewhere else to step
two blocks away from downtown
they going to tackle your ass.
You know, they let you get
aggressive with yourself.
Look at you, the guy go.
Fuck y'all.
hit a crack pipe right in front of them
They just laugh and drive up.
You know, it's how you do.
These people don't nothing but
what I need sometime every now and then
and even a little bitty dude
like me just need a hug every now
and then this is show some people
some love, man that's all they need.
That's all these people
need this community.
There ain't nothing wrong with down here.
Just a little love, Mark.
You know, that's about my story.
You know, I'm gonna
keep going forward, man.
And every time I get a chance
to try to encourage something
I do, I do it even in my drawings man.
I just, I just like to
see people do better.
I didn't want to get better at bed older.
I ain't going to get bigger
get old and just tell people this a story.
I want to tell you from
experience because when
I'm dead and gone, I want to
leave some type of legacy.
Like you doing photographer.
You know something.
I had a little art gallery, you know
just a little office rental offer where
if you know anything about
San Bernardino, it was
it was orange grove and waterman.
They had these little office rent 300
and some dollars that
turned into an art gallery.
That was my little art gallery man.
And then as soon as I bring some guys
from down here, gang members, what they do
they kick the door in
thinking I was in there.
My same friends, man got him on camera
but I couldn't go to court.
I couldn't press charges.
I wouldn't be walking around.
We not allowed to call the police.
So that's my life story, Mark.
I don't, you know, I know to this.
Oh, one more thing is
I was writing a friend.
His name is he from my area.
And I know he got to deal
with a lot of burdens.
They just, his friends
shot my friend in the park
in our park, embarrassed
him and let the gun
like boom, boom, boom,
shot him all in the face.
And the gun jammed back and just smoke.
The girls said it broke, but
I say nah, it jammed back.
It cost that man his family
for trying to be impressive
trying to be a gang member.
He killed somebody, but never
thinking about what goes
on what lurks around. By him doing that.
That park is so many
people in powerful gangs.
They went over to his
house, opened the door
killed his mom, killed his Aunty
killed his brother, killed
his sister, killed everybody.
That type of shit, you know?
So when I was in prison, this, this
this is strike a nerve is
how you encourage somebody.
You want a gang member.
You one of them hardcore gang members.
You go in jail.
The shortest person on the yard.
Besides me, that was going
coming home was my cellie
and he get out in 2069.
That's the earliest dude on the yard.
They got EPRDs
which means earliest possible
release date 3016, 7,020.
Without a life sentence.
You know, this is what happens
when you pull the trigger.
When you take somebody's
life, we gonna take your life
but we gonna take your life mentally.
You say you can handle it.
I think guys handle it.
When you get to the five years
just like a plane hitting
fucking turbulence.
You start breaking apart.
You start coming apart.
After five years you started coming apart.
I never thought I was going
to come up out of there
You see the three ways
you're going to come
out of there too.
Wise. Like they was telling
me they was schooling me
because it was tricky.
When I went to prison,
guys was telling, Hey homie
come on in and let's shoot
a game of dominoes, homie.
He try why you turn your head.
They try to knock you up.
Like my homeboy.
He's the guy you've been seeing on TV.
If you remember them stories about
the guy that the police put
in the cell that he raped that other guy.
That's her old man's brother.
(unclear)
Raped him, (unclear)
Today Raymond, tomorrow his name is Renee.
Today you call yourself Raymond
but tomorrow you saying
it out of your own mouth.
My name ain't Raymond, I'm Renee.
You know, it's funny, I'm telling you.
(laughs)
It happened like that.
It was happening just like that.
These are gang members.
This is what your own
friends talked about.
You, you put in all that work.
You hard, you I'm going to
know what a homeboy did.
. They'd be calling your Tabitha tomorrow.
You know, they, they did not care, man.
Um, ut he told me
Gangster, they said
there's only three ways.
You can come out of prison.
And I'm a little dude.
I was like, they going to walk through
to the last right here.
You know what I mean?
They would pick me up and try to run.
So I used to always do push up.
This is why I got so strong.
They tell me that it's
three ways you can come
up and you better not fuck up, Commodore.
Wise, a homosexual, or in a box.
The only three ways you can come home.
And he said, your choice.
So he reached in the back
between the cheeks of his ass.
He gave him a gang of balloons. Weed.
Weed balloons. He said, here.
Get yourself right in here.
I'm going to bring you some cosmetics.
I'm going to bring you there.
And he kept looking at me.
Y'all do his mouth.
They be looking at you like that.
Like you ain't shit, everything.
I'm just finna.
I'm finna.
Wait, how you say that?
What's the word you want to
say. Not eye fuck you, but
But I'm a rape you with my
eyes right front of you.
You gonna see me looking at you.
licking your lips and saying,
yeah, you can come on.
Move with me.
Anytime they saying like that boldly.
You say man, fuck you.
And they said, well, what you gonna do?
Cause they've been in there for awhile.
You mean you looking like (unclear)
And he do like this he's walking away.
He made me like
y'all got y'all we joking,
but he ain't, he ain't joking.
Them guys do not give a fuck about us.
That's in prison.
They don't want to hear your story.
They don't wanna hear
nothing about pastime.
They just want to get out.
So that's what I got.
- All right, Commodore. Thank
you for sharing your story.
That's my story.